[Music]
here we
go Ellie
[Music]
hello ah took me took me a while to get
the stream
going should probably delete the other
two streams here one second I'll just
take my screen offline for a second so I
can check this out
um
yeah these here need to be
deleted all right
I think I have
it now let's bring need to zoom you
people
in all right Merry Christmas everyone um
nurs was
excellent so we'll be we'll be just uh
hanging around um playing playing
hopefully some some
Minecraft
so uh Let's do let's do that
um
good screen
back there we
go
and we're here I haven't played
Minecraft in a long while
um so let's
see
yeah we'll play on normal I'm not good
enough for U for anything else
so is this I'm
seeing all right I'm seeing myself with
like a 30 second lag or something like
this that seems a bit excessive but
there's probably nothing I can do right
now so you'll you people will just have
to uh endure being a bit behind me also
let me know if the uh if the game audio
and my voice are too much in Conflict um
tell me if I have to turn one up or down
or
so there we go that's it all right um
let's do
that oh um let's switch the controls
around
so I want to Sprint with this and I want
to sneak with this and
then
um that seems all very good and where is
the inventory
e this seems fine yeah there we go there
we go let's check out where we landed so
we appear to be in
a we appear to be in a bit of
uh what's it called Prairie
no a bunch of
tree like one as one
does multiplayer no I don't I don't
otherwise I can't stop whenever I
want and yeah
so Mouse is a bit
too bit too finicky I
feel
so I'm going to it's going to be a while
before I get the whole
um the uh
stuff down really to how I want it um
I'll probably also have to change
the acceleration is that a
thing
no pointer acceleration there we go
let's turn that off this is a bit slow
but that's
fine
so all right
yeah this seems
better now I have to go back and
actually okay this is
terrible I don't know how to operate a
mouse anymore all right but this is okay
good um so wait did I make an axe or not
[Music]
no
no I can't this is way more terrible
than
before I don't know why
but I'll just live with it um good I
have two
axes no no no why why did I do
that ah I'm so bored at this
game
[Music]
a redstone GPT model in Minecraft it's
going to take a while you know I built
two four neuron no a six neuron uh
neuron Network back in the day and it
took me a while that was I think that
was a Christmas live stream no so let's
see what we build today my plan is just
do to play a bit and
uh have some
um have some stuff for other people
who are maybe not as uh accompanied at
Christmas so we'll just dig for some uh
for some
[Music]
Diamond there we
go
um int value neurons yes yes it's a
whole thing with red stone and whatnot
so
um you can go watch it I think it's
still live the live streams were
terrible because I I chose to uh
stream with OBS capturing a window and
for some reason OBS can only do that at
like three frames a second or so but it
was it was okay and then made a big
video about
it can you prove that it's not AI is
playing no no no no in fact probably if
I manage to do anything at all here that
is proof that it's
AI because I am not very good at
Minecraft there is a cave let's
go let's go oh that looks like that
looks
reasonably
[Music]
explorable um yeah I have no weapons at
all
[Music]
so
um probably probably better a stone
sword
no
and isn't there some kind of Shield like
this but I need iron right yeah probably
need iron and I probably also need some
torches
uhuh good there we
go there's
iron look at that
um do I need a do I need like a good
pickaxe for the iron probably don't know
how
this works
anymore the music kills you
why it's good music
um how can you not like Minecraft
music all right there we go pickaxe
achieved
iron
Acquired and then we need an oven and
then we make ourselves a big old shield
and then we go explore the
downstairs all right um
oven I just the shadow
lighting like the brightness
[Music]
how like this
bright I hope that's better
no did I set
it yeah it's on full bright
now
so
oven Boop yep furnace it's not called an
oven
oh well um
Iron
collecting Crea an llm the
processes
what find a cure for hair loss that's
going to be we'll will'll solve world
hunger before we solve hair
loss because because okay CU it's it's
economically advantageous to not solve
hair loss because you can just keep
selling some kind of remedies to
it as whereas uh for world hunger
there's not really that much money in
solving in keep pretending to solve it
so
incentives all right Shield actually
let's just do
this
uhhuh and we're probably good so far
so and we'll put this here here there we
go something like this
no oh you I hear some
zombie we could kind of make this our
base and we go down
here oh wow that goes down
far uh we get down
there we dig we dig like Minecraft uhoh
well that was
[Laughter]
it
all
right there monsters coming at night
well there monsters coming whenever it's
dark um
so where was I down
there so the problem is that they're not
very
friendly
GG um so yeah the plan is to go get our
stuff again
obviously can't just let that sit on
us we will dig down and we will find and
we will avenge and I first have to
figure out where where that exactly
was
because okay let's retrace our steps we
went up right to the big
tree and then we saw the the entry to
the
cave here we saw the entry to the
cave
there all right we can do
[Music]
this here that's where we were okay
first zombie we're wholly unequipped for
for that
one
um crafting
[Music]
skills oops uh what you
get ow ow
ow so the problem is night is arriving
right and
um we are very unprepared for night very
unprepared
so
um ow ow ow well this is not too
nice
it's all right we lost our stuff twice
I'm very bad at this how
about how about we just start again and
we do it the right
way
so we'll first build a shelter we'll get
some food going and so on like we'll do
what you're supposed to do okay this is
good we immediately have
water uh we have sheep we have
horses we have some lava back there this
is a very good we have a v this will be
like this will be
like what's the oh oh gee
like okay so um this is like the
ultimate speedrun spawn though it's
probably a desert missing this is
insane it's just wood that's kind of
missing from the immediate surroundings
here but other than that we can make
ourselves some wood so other than that
this is this is the greatest spawn ever
let's
go if I somehow probably manage will
manage to screw this up but
a competent player could uh make
something out of
this all right here we go
Villages it's almost easy right it's
almost too easy uh
no a bed kitty kit we'll get some pets
later so we we'll just focus on
looting the whole village and uh
[Music]
we could go for a speedrun but then also
I'm incompetent at speed running um
hello no
[Music]
okay finding villages
cheating I'm sorry I'm
sorry I know it's
cheating well we won't make we won't do
we won't make use of it too much okay
how about that how about how about we'll
kind of just get initial supplies and
we'll leave the villagers largely to
themselves until later where we can
trade a bit with
them we're here
already where's the hey
usually they have tons of
hay would be nice so I don't have to
farm for some for
bread
okay and oh down there there's more
stuff
okay and thank you thank you thank you
thank
you
well cartographer ah there we go
good
good still didn't find the hay but don't
need the
hay
okay so now we uh we can we can kind of
we can
start Jesus what kind of Spawn is this
this is
insane hello respect me I'm your new
god
um excellent all right trees
wood we'll go go over
there because that's where we came
from build your own village and host
people from other
Villages I think
so I think if if there's a bed it kind
of counts as a village no at least if I
remember correctly so let's cther some
wood and then build a
shelter and then survive the
night we still don't have coal yet so
we'll need to do
that or we can just skip the night
because we're speed
running
um
good
uhhuhh how about we
get some sticks going and
then we get an
Axe and a pickaxe
hopefully all
right there's coal that's what we were
missing then we have it
all this Nook right here we can probably
use as
shelter probably if we manage to light
it all out it's going to be a nice
shelter so first let's get the
coal
uhhuh is AI equal compression jeez who
knows probably
I mean
the the question the question kind of is
um let's say like we can only compress
stuff
because so it's not Universal
compression right cuz Universal
compression would mean you can compress
any signal but what we what humans are
good at do is compressing signal that
are important to
humans um so it's not a universal
compression it's a compression of very
particular signals and the tradeoff is
that we've been obviously given the
encoding and decoding handbook let's say
by The evolutionary
process which is severely limiting what
kind of signals we can
compress so
yeah I'm pretty sure AGI is not just
compression um but human level
intelligence has probably a lot to do
with compressing signals that humans
care about so different different stuff
right at least I feel that's different
stuff all right should we build the
shovel um
bang good and might as well get one of
these so now we we have to uh close off
we will we take some dirt here so we can
close up the uh our
house
let's not pick straight down again
because that would
be he overfit on a terabyte of data
isn't that very good compression
algorithm yeah exactly but it's also
useless except all you care about is
that exact terabyte of data in fact you
can compress it down to zero
bytes or maybe one bit which is just is
is what you is what you want to transmit
that particular terabyte of data or not
like you've compressed the terabyte of
data to one bit so if if someone is
given the code
book then compression is really
easy but uh also useless because you can
only transmit the one thing
so you see what I mean
therefore uh we'll also get some food
going got some uh
some yeah because we're kind of low
on and then we make a little field
with
uh with
wheat
wheat sweet wheat all right more coal
give me
coal do you think the configuration of
models hold interesting info about the
data train
on yeah sure I mean it it needs to right
that's literally really the the
premise of stuff of of machine learning
that the models themselves hold kind
of
data uh hold the hold the a some some
sort of an abstraction of of the data
that it was trained
on
so
all
right so what we need to get going
is
field a Field
farm a farm and for that we want
to
expand expand our borders here a little
bit like so
there we
go and then we need probably we need one
of them one of them
hes how do I do that like this yeah okay
there we
go
die all right and then we probably going
to need
some some
weed
seeds boom boom boom
good probably collect some more but we
should probably also collect some uh
some animals
no the
cat hey cat oh we can get the we can get
the cat as a pet no by is it
fish
okay thank
you
mhm
good all right
where was that
cat hey where was it there it is so look
look cat look fish fishy fishy fishy
fish yeah yeah yeah fishy fishy
fish where does it
go where did the cat
go I hear the cat but I don't see the
cat there is the cat hey Cat hey Cat
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cat
no stop it stop
it get out of there where are you
going why is
it
cat
cat oh that was not smart right that's
going to wash down the cat
cat where are we
going this is not a smart idea
cat all right there we
go follow me follow me
up come
Kitty come Kitty
Kitty come
here there's the
hay
yeah
ah this excellent
excellent that's what we
wanted most valuable possession of
villages this will feed us for quite the
foreseeable
future they don't have any use for it
they'll just store it here so it's
actually okay to take
it there's our
house hey
cat look at our
house yeah there you go
this is where we
live stealing on
Christmas yeah what are you going to do
about
it okay
um what else so I feel this is probably
not going to be enough so we'll have to
expand this over time um also we have
some wheat now
uh so we probably can get some some
animals to to to come
here but we'll probably need the sort
of that's not call it a cage more like
a
enclosement first for the lovely animals
that we're going to bring here
so um we'll make that
now so there's a nice open field here
and we need some some
wood and then we can
make we can make an
enclosement I didn't mean the cat to
feed us for a
while that would be
well be
something all right more
wood cat cat cat cat cat cat
cat
yes all right um so we now make a
enclosement for that we
need somehow we need
uh planks and then we
need this this thing here Oak fence no
um we don't have more we need
stick
okay and Oak
fence okay and we need fence gate fence
gate there we go yes
cat
correct cat is very
demanding
um should probably clear this area
here in order to make room
for set
enclosement or we just don't care bring
the animals back
here I like the
lva pet cat can I can I pet it isn't it
just like make it sit and not
sit like
that I don't know is there another
petting all right that was it for our
trusty
shovel
let's attempt to
uh build the
fence although if we
have we can replace one side with a uh
you can replace one
side
with a two block High thing
no like if we clear this until the two
block Mark we can use this as
a side of the fence
shift shift and
left how how do I know I'm not going to
punch the
cat okay let's try shift and or
[Music]
CR shift I I re uh
I remap shift to
[Music]
running all
right so
fence boom boom boom
[Music]
boom
all right
and here's that gate come
cat it's getting dark so okay we should
get some animals but also we should go
underground and do some actual
Minecrafting
no kind of pro Minecrafting
[Music]
getting animals is
boring we have enough food we have
enough coal we have some
armor we just dig we can just
dig let's
go I mean we should probably get some
[Music]
wood that's the that's the thing we're
missing we're missing wood
um so yeah that's kind of the last
Supply we need before we go uh super
duper
underground also there used to be a tree
somewhere here so we should find some
saplings that we can
maybe set
where was
it no all right so we'll go to the trees
up there get some wood and then we're
good to go
cow
cow all right change of plans there is a
cow here we might just want to get
it back is there a second
one no okay one cow's not going to not
going to be enough yeah Ry
[Music]
cow it's all Shader packs I'm not going
to I'm not going to see I'm not going to
play for that
long so that the Shader packs are going
to be worth it I'm
afraid no
the cat's going to stay
here while we go
underground whatever we do we must not
endanger the
[Music]
cat
we should take a baseline for any
percent it would probably be good to
measure some AGI against because I'm not
very good and therefore it probably be
be an okay Benchmark like if you
can beat me at
Minecraft you probably can do something
but not very
much
I just want this tree to decompose there
we go the last bit of Axe we
had cow how about you come with
me how about you come with
me yeah you
friends any friends no all right so
we'll go down there
cow and
uh we'll go into the enclosed area that
I have made for you is that
[Music]
okay
hi voo vco sorry ah you
are zero FF
nice there it
is the enclosed area that's not a
cage no no don't go lost don't go
lost
good
excellent you get
one all right we have wood last thing we
needed let's go let's make some make
some
planks and we're fully equipped cat you
stay here we are going to go
underground
all right how about the goal for today
is to find one
diamond and mine
it don't even have iron
yet
gbd4 has read a million Minecraft
tutorials yeah yeah it will be
interesting be interesting I mean
there's already a lot of work in
Minecrafting copper we have copper all
right we have we are
somewhere we are
somewhere
nice okay
so more
torches
good um yeah so now we
need no how does bread
go so now we need I need some supplies
here red first and foremost how does red
go ah there we
go
good
um we have a pickaxe we don't have any
sort of weapon yet so we'll do that
next
um from this we can probably make some
sticks from this we
can probably make some planks no there
are planks
already shovel we have a
shovel
pickaxe probably need another
pickaxe
um axe we'll probably need that we're
already running out of
space and we'll probably we need a
sword there we
go that should be do
it
no
okay we will not make the same mistakes
again will not repeat the mistakes of
our
ancestors which is me 15 minutes
ago if you were to describe Nur
this year in a few
phrases
of there's a lot of llm
stuff there is a lot of completely
irrelevant
stuff and that's just a property of
Academia um
because because you have to publish
something right and there's so many
people in research right now so they all
have to do something um so people go
into these absolute niches which is good
right that's I guess that's what what
research is supposed to be that you
become the very best at jeez
what at the very best at
something but it's also quite you know
it's just look at
that would you look at
that oh we made the same mistake
again we did it
again cat it's good that we didn't take
you
along very good very good
call all right I suck at this but this
seed is
good I have my own stream open to read
chat and um so I could I could see my
death
again which was nice which is very
nice
[Music]
horse I'm lacking safe exploration
yes this could be this is this is
exactly why safe RL is a thing
otherwise
people would act like
me all right that's the the Woody
part we'll collect some young trees here
to
set those are all probably
yep and we'll head
back hey
Spidey uh-oh hello
creep tempted to just go to the Village
honestly they are better they're better
at this than
me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay now the question is
okay reward function isn't
correct
yep all
right well we only need to get to our
stuff right oh there's
C
hello
hello why is it not oh it's burning
again good good good good
good all right well I already have a
crafting table that was
unnecessary so we'll need another
pickaxe and and we'll probably need some
some torches along the
way and our only mission is to get to
our
stuff
Kitty we will avenge
us which is below like 100 blocks yeah I
know
stuff will despawn probably by the time
I'll get there that's
correct all right so there down there is
our
stuff I think we're literally in the
ceiling of this
place
um yeah but that is not going to deter
us so
so you
know we'll keep
going ah these are
the stall tights things
no yeah we are in the
ceiling this is uh not an optimal
optimal
strategy take off the glasses it's too
dark maybe that's why I keep falling
true Diamond seem a
farfetch if I can't even get get to the
bottom of
something you you may be correct you may
be
correct
[Music]
um that was close that was not intended
again the
ceiling
so um we should
dig this direction no this is also the
ceiling all of it is the CE
healing may need a different
strategy how about how about we continue
here and go this
way maybe some water yeah yeah we could
drop
down for now let's try the classic
way
um torch torch
torch our torches won't last very long I
have the
feeling
again
ceiling we're just sitting a top a giant
hole I don't know what to
do we could drop down with some water
but we need to find some iron or
something so
I'm afraid this is not the
way let's get some coal and let's dig in
a different
direction that's the plan for
now where do we at the
coal that
mountain yep
can also explore what's over
here
pumpkins
excellent
Piggies
[Music]
um make an
axe does the Iron Golem drop iron yes it
does it does but I will not count on
myself to
[Music]
be competent enough because you kind of
have to get up on
a on a two or three block thing and then
what there's so many animals
here
how do I have something to no I don't
have anything
to so it's just going to
be going leave two of them for later
and we'll just see if there's some coal
exposed
anywhere that seems
promising you should invite Benjo Hinton
look out to the server yeah why
not
they can see firsthand what it's it's
like to be to try to do this very very
hard AGI
task more
cow
more cow but no
coal why Minecraft why not it is a
enjoyable game and it's Christmas and
it's Trad to
stream Minecraft on
Christmas at least on this channel it
is probably have enough wood for now
hello
coal
Coal does anyone have some coal for
me there's something but it's not c
ah oh no
I'm going to die I'm going to
die get away get away get away get away
get away get away I'm going to die I
told
you I'm so bad at this game am am I
not at least the cat's still alive
that's a good thing so actually now what
we can do is we can
go get the cow and then make more
cows and then we have a stable supply of
at least of
food so where was
it somewhere
there
and we're not going to get the cow now
right cuz it's
dark but we might get our
stuff if we're
lucky there we
go
all right let's head back
to
there organize a server and play all
together yeah but usually such projects
they always take a ton longer to set up
than to actually
imp and by the time everyone's together
playing everyone has to go
already all right hello Mr
skeleton not
today
we're still looking for
coal
okay still looking for
coal oh there we go that was
easy
um and I should probably
ah that was
dumb
here
good we have some
coal we can probably go ow hey
wait it's not going to die as long as
it's in
water all right all right I'm going to
die again am I
not
yay so let's make
furnace and then we can
wow we can
uh cook some
meat oh
you Merry
Christmas
everyone hope you're all doing
fine
our stuff is probably despawned by now
no I would strongly assume I would
strongly
assume it's pretty much
gone
all right we can set
these so when we die the next
time pet the
cat there you
go I had some fish in the other
stuff
so giant hole that's where we left
off
here again giant
hole so how about we go this way until
there's no longer a giant
hole I have a
feeling can I step on these on these
ones drip stone that does not sound like
something you want to step on
right without knowing exactly what it is
it does not sound like I necessarily
want to step on
dripstone I might be wrong
though
there it is again drip
Stone so we might risk going one down
yes giant
hole let's go forward we'll just go
forward for until there's no more giant
pole under
us giant
hole what is
this
ah well
um how about we place torch here and
then we go that
way and at least we find some
iron you can step on it you can mine
down from water source yeah
yeah okay I can step on it thank you
that is
helpful
and still a giant
hole so
uh let's not go
there and let's see
still aant
to H we've gotten ourselves into a bit
of trouble
now jump on the water where is water I
don't know where I don't know where
water is
so
um yeah so that's the a bit of the
problem I need stick
stick stick and then I need
axe if we find
water we'll go down really
fast how about we go this
way
down that's good down
that's
good still
okay still
good we may have found an actual
way
nice
there's this is
viable this is
viable this is a viable
path
nice all right we need I feel we need to
prepare a bit to go out there
doesn't seem too
safe
uh probably need
this we uh have
idiotically melted down all of our coal
we only have four Stakes
left um
yeah we get a we can get a sword um
can we somehow if we put do we have the
iron
here if we put the iron what else what
can we
burn that
works
um food goes here this goes here this
goes
here that's probably
good
excellent we are going to need a
shield cuz we only had one Shield so
far good and what do we do with the rest
make a pickaxe or a sword probably a
pickaxe is smarter
no probably
smarter all right let's
go
yeah that's a big
hole that is a very big hole
hello
[Music]
hello thank
you these things are just going to fall
down from now on
right put everything valuable in a chest
there that is a
smart you see I don't play Minecraft too
often that is a really smart
idea all right uh chest can we build a
chest no is there something I need for a
CH ah there we
go all
right oh
no
all right
so we'll take some of
the this is the only wood we have
left that's a
bit we probably need most of oh no
there's more wood um we'll probably need
a lot of this stuff no uh
I mean there's not too much valuable
stuff it's just so that it doesn't
clutter up our
inventory
um yeah so we'll slowly start making our
way
down
now the question is where did our
original stuff fall
down if we could get
that that would
be excellent but I have a feeling
I have a feeling that's not going to be
so
easy you play Minecraft once a year yeah
that's about that's about the
frequency
good
um where did we come
from now I already forgot over
here
good
[Music]
almost got me
almost blue stuff
very
good ah see we're not actually at the
bottom this is just an intermediate
platform
um
so question is what do we do with this
oh there's a skeleton
somewhere
ow
Hey
well I have no clue where that came
from did we find the equipment I I have
a slight feeling we're not going to get
our equipment back a slight
feeling if you ask me
ah there we go there you
are
H ooh
wow
glowfish I don't know what they're
called
but yeah we're probably not going to get
our stuff back I have no clue where it
is
um
so what can we do from
here
we are going to die here aren't
we
gold oh I need the good pickaxe for that
now
you should get back your iron gear I
know I know I don't know where it is
though be nice if we got everything back
but
I don't feel that's the case although we
do find some Iron Coal is our biggest
problem ironically
now the iron gear was unfairly
looted from a village anyway so maybe
that's Karma that
um told us that that was not
okay I mean it was my very very very bad
skills at the game
but it does make sense if it were
Karma
all right here we go
um if anyone sees
coal let me know
got a ton of iron channel plays
Minecraft
yeah do
some um yeah
coal big problem
[Music]
H you know we can just resort to the
good old
cheating that's
possible and give ourselves Some
Coal cuz I'm
[Music]
out could an AGI cheat that's the
question why is the red net architecture
slow to catch on probably because it's
not that good
probably because it's kind of it's kind
of
bad doesn't deliver on the things that
it uh was advertised
on that's usually why stuff doesn't
catch
on not a deeper meaning behind it or so
so it's
just not
very not very good
um yeah oh there we go didn't see
that
you is Mamba better than red
net
uh tricky I guess I don't
know this all of this like is like
remains to be seen right because
ultimately you have to try it out ideas
are look at the fusion models right the
idea sounds okay but also kind of sounds
a bit dumb it's like okay what if we
just took noise and then we just learn
to revert the noise one step at a time
and you like well
okay maybe but then people try it
actually works right um so with mumo
it's like well what if we just kind of
didn't do aen
and just sort of did an
RNN and uh you're like oh well okay
maybe that could
work I mean we already know
rnn's
work
for for deep learning um it's just that
they don't scale very
well but they
[Music]
work all right so we went here here here
here down
here now that we have uh tches again a
new
[Music]
game I like the new this new Terrain
generation seems
very very um I don't know engaging
there's obstacles and
stuff very
good we have so much
[Music]
iron
I yeah I'm
uh I'm a hoarder can you
tell when I see something that's rare
I'm like ooh I must get
it more coal
excellent except copper I don't know if
copper is good for anything is it can
you do electricity stuff with
it hear a
[Music]
skelet
history yes the history of AI is going
to be they build bigger models but but
the crucial bit in that is
um you need architectures that can
support the scaling and that's the
crucial bit right and that's why the
Transformer is good because it it can
scale really well so you can build big
stuff that makes use of scale
and that's ultimately why the
Transformer is kind of popular because
it it just scales well it's just a an
architecture that um you can throw tons
and tons and tons of data at it and and
compute and it can handle it and you can
make it bigger if you need to without
much much trouble whereas like an RNN
not so much um RNN
will even out flatten out at some point
and you need tons of tricks to get the
gradient gradient going and so on yeah
no one has built a 70b RNN because and
when you want to train it right you need
to do single sample back prop through
time and so on whereas with a
Transformer you put in a
single single text sequence and boom you
have L training samples right you have L
times a loss that you can back propop
and that's so your L time your sequence
length times faster in training for
almost the the same
compute and that's the good thing that's
why causal masking causal masking isn't
is not
necessary The Way We Do It Like It's
actually kind of restrictive but um the
point is wait wait wait wait what's
going on
skeleton um there we
go yeah yeah
yeah but the point is it it allows you
to do this this
training right and that's ultimately
what makes the model good
is it can actually support and handle
the scale and that's why the the state
space models are also good candidate
because there too you can kind of train
them in uh in this parallel fashion so
you're not you're not just restricted to
using one training example at a time
because every token the prediction of
every token can be trained kind of at
the same time and
that's that's the
ultimately the deciding
thing of why you want to use model
architectures oh nice M
shaft so we're low on food so I
hope hope that in this m shaft we're
going to find some some sort of food um
need to get down first though so let's
try
here nope
nope double
NOP can probably get over there
somehow
yep
one pork chop
left our stuff is gone isn't
it
ah
it's quite unlikely to find food in
these
right I
believe
um
torches fake twitch
streamer it's a bit of a tradition on
this
channel every Christmas we'll play some
Minecraft and we're having a fun time
and I try to not die too
often that's the
deal all right
it's we're not going to get food soon
right I have a
feeling we are going to run out of
food
soon
and that's sub
optimal
we could go back to the Overworld and
get some
food sorry about the Miss misnomer we
are in the Overworld um
but
so you know what I mean above
ground spider goulash does that
exist uh-oh oh no
I don't I I I never know the mechanics
of these
things
[Music]
hello
oh there we
[Laughter]
go I did not expect that I did not
expect diamond we fulfilled our goal for
the
day look at us
How Far We've
Come light it with a torch and it will
stop spawning thank
you look at us how far we've
come end stream yeah we fulfilled our
goal we set out to find the diamond and
we found one
in a Cheesy
way but even a Cheesy way he's a
way
so you
know
and
hello can I eat the glowberries
runs with 50 yeah I should probably make
some armor
right I probably should
that's also going to
be a
uh a good way to save on some
food all right so
iron where's me iron there we
go
we can make an iron farm later although
I feel in this stream we won't we won't
get far enough to make to make anything
else than get back back to the Overworld
you can eat glowberries
good
good let's see
well they don't give too
much
no um well before we make armor actually
we need an iron pickaxe
probably we can probably live with the
sword for
now we need a helmet and boots and
stuff
boots
yeah took us this long to get back to
the exact same armor level that we
were about an hour ago full set of
diamond
armor yeah not getting there
today sadly I have a feeling
[Music]
um I have a
feeling
pants and where are the
pants and we can probably soon make
little
helmet no need one
more all
right we're probably okay with armor now
let's just smelt the things through then
we're
good meanwhile we can explore
some although I have the feeling if I do
that not going to go too
well
so our goal should be to find our way
back to above how about that how about
our last goal for today is to make it
back to the
cat cuz we really like the
cat and she's probably probably missing
us if you and we can name the
cat so we need a enough we need to save
enough iron don't we need like to name
the cat we probably need
uh I'm not sure how name tags work but
we need an anvil
right why not go
deeper because it is how how many hours
are we into this stream well just one or
so
okay
we need to retain enough iron to build
an
anvil and then
um then we can name stuff need an anval
to rename see yeah okay so and for an
anvil there's like a ton of iron
required right so we'll just store iron
so we can name our
cut 32
iron not not quite there
yet
um oh we have the five here
uh uh no we need to make you of the fire
32 we're going to get to
32 we're okay we're
fine
so yeah we need to decide what to name
the
cat and
uh then we can go and name the
cat
that will be
it cat
GPT
tempting
tempting to name it cat GPT yes yes yes
I like the the creativity in
that
[Music]
um good all right Kitty we're
coming r
[Music]
um well how
about
I don't
know what what famous researchers name
can be
added can be uh if you add like a meow
or
something sounds
funny
tokens would be yum
yum yeah oh this is uhoh is this uh I
know thought this was all of that
Falling Sand we're not that deep look at
that we're not actually super duper deep
this is already this is
already already looks like we're
above don't have shovel
though
uh let's hope it's not night for too
long
and there we go that's not too bad so
now we need to build big
tower so that we know where to go
in okay and now where are we
at
um where is
[Music]
home where is
home
[Music]
H is it okay we can
probably we can probably see we are so
so uh this here goes further in X and
this here so we'll probably need to go
about that way right to go back to to
spawn this decreases in
X and then this de increases in Z
yeah
so let's go
there Kitty we're
coming yeah there's the
village
here we are there we go there's the oh
nope nope nope nope almost
died we need to keep the name tag very
important hello singular cow there is
Kitty f
yeah
yeah yeah okay uh so Anvil okay
um I believe we need like a block of
iron though
um like this no okay so good and now we
can do
Anvil Anvil requires three block of iron
all
right one more one
more
good
okay
[Music]
um they really don't do much to
and will goes and will goes
here so where do I put
it here all right we need the name
kadwani
no
no better
names Yan
[Laughter]
lookat that is good that is
good Yan
cat all right okay just confirm if I
press enter here am I doing the right
thing because I only have I only have
this one name
tag shut GPT
yeah just just if if I need to know I
need to know I'm not doing the the
completely wrong thing
here
[Music]
oh thank you thank
you oh there we
[Laughter]
go we need to get the
fish oh food
food food
nice
[Music]
um we need some Farm later like some
automated thing but for now weren't
there fish here at some point did I just
did I kill them all already oh no there
they
are
hey oh
no uh this
one okay got one fish there's the
other that is a deep
lake deep deep lake
coold
more
coal okay cat y y
cat how about a
fish yes yes yes yes yes what do you
say
nice
okay what the what's the is there like a
screenshot command there must be
no
cinematic as the sun
sunet us and Y the cat go to
sleep Al
four I'm not falling for that and I have
a Mac
so F2
okay nice okay
um what we want to do is we want to
get the kitty in the
moment
nope trying to position
myself
crap and I screwed it
up
I only have the one fish
so needs to be from the side right
like
[Music]
come on can't switch my fingers that
quickly
nice I hope that was okay we'll see
um very good so I don't know we want to
go for one one last hooray
Adventure like one last
thing we could go down again but we do
need I feel we need a lot more
food um The Village we've already
plundered we have one
cow we can't eat the cat
so what do we do get more fish don't
think that's going to go very far but we
could get we could get some more
fish
hello
ow ow
ow of
course I'm an idiot I can't do
underwater stuff so let's see pumpkins
can I eat pumpkins probably
not some animals around o another cow
okay oh
hello that is a nice
surprise some
chickens and
good
first we'll feed them and then they need
their
end
hello so we'll collect some
some some meat then we'll go down
again we'll try to get an adventure
go
um don't
need what do I not
need I feel like I can eat
this
good
um
[Music]
dirt
fishing rod get the fish with the
fishing
rod is that infinite
fish but it's luck dependent
[Music]
right so I don't
know
[Music]
fish
huzzah all right we probably have enough
food for one
trip let's quickly cook it all and we
can
go
um this
here this
here and the beef
there and going to need another
chest
Jesus was symbolized as a fish
okay to put all
of that stuff in here that we don't
need at all
um this this here don't
care wheat we can probably make use
of and the iron probably uh save the
iron optionally make another
pickaxe yeah I think we're pretty good
fishing
rod let's make
one just for
[Music]
Giggles why am i Fishing when there are
like tons of fish over
there
all
right that's probably enough enough
food is RL HF needed who
knows who knows
big
questions without
answers are we in a
simulation again big questions who
knows C what's wrong with
you y the
cat all right is the fish ready it's
ready let's
go
we are
armed not to the teeth but we're armed
okay we'll go down we'll beat somebody
up I don't care
who just
somebody oh no we can see where there
are stuff is still there we just ride
down the
water into the huzzah
right we just do that
let's get some
water so we need a
bucket uh isn't it like so yeah we're
going to get some
water
and we are going
to
get go
down right where we fell off was this
where we fell off
initially where we fell
down or did did we fall
down over there
somewhere
H so okay so uh let's assume we fell
down here if I were
to sort of block this off then block
this stuff off like
so and and
uh like
so and put the water
here just want to be able to get
back by swimming
up all right everyone
ready everybody ready
let's
go
oh
well let's go
again
ow ah you again and creeper
but the good thing is the good thing is
we can just go again
no now that we have the
water we don't even need to do
anything we just go for as long as it
takes the creeper is gone now
so
there we go
one there's the little zombie
again
two come on come
on die
die we are going
going as long as it
takes wa the zombie can take the
armor
what
no no I don't want that that is going to
be many many deaths from me until it
dies
there we go you die die
die There's a Zombie behind me there
is
[Music]
um and
died the problem is I don't see anything
down there cooked salmon is the best
weapon do I look like I can manage my
inventory optimally at the same
time I don't think so
so all right here we go
again it's getting a bit too
dark make good use of anything I can
just jump around and uh punch the air
there we
go
good there's another zombie around but
okay
um that one's not a danger right
now appreciate
that let's
heal
[Music]
aha there you
go all
[Music]
right ah crap crap crap all right
good too bad is that diamond
[Music]
what I would like to get my weapons back
eventually that's some of my
weapons
this is Diamond
so unfortunately no
torches more
Shield is this
diamond is this
[Music]
diamond
where is an iron pickaxe when you need
one all right
well my there's a
helmet my torches seem to be
gone it seems to be diamonds
so our if our plan was to mine a
diamond that would be it but we need
iron and for that we need
coal and my iron pickaxe is
gone we use the last the last of our
iron to make the bucket to get
here
suboptimal
suboptimal and I don't see my stuff
anywhere rest of my stuff is not
[Music]
here oh well
your iron pickax is in the dark yeah
yeah I know that's a bit the
problem I have
no clue where so if I take the torch and
I
just walk over here and place it
here see it's not
[Music]
here
and
also
not
[Music]
here
and also not
[Music]
here all right I have a
plan we go up
we get
coal we come down we find iron we mine
the
diamond to the left of the
[Music]
stream the left to the left of the
Stream
here well there's a
zombie
[Music]
there's nothing minable
around
left well left could be anywhere know
uh like
that thank
[Music]
you uh-oh was that
skeleton yeah that appears to be a
skeleton ouch well this is the end this
is the
end
ow the end of
goodbye
goodbye oh
well at
least at least we have
us y cat at least we have
us and with that I think it's a good
good time to end end the stream
um thank
you for being here um I hope this for
everyone who's
uh who doesn't know what to do on
Christmas that this was at least a
little bit a little bit enjoyable um
and yeah I hope we'll do it again soon
maybe we can stream something
else but this was
fun yes yes yes I know I
know uh yeah with that I wish you an
extremely Pleasant rest of the year um
we'll hear from each
other
and yeah until next time thanks thanks
for being here let's see if AGI doesn't
catch us
first
goodbye